All five of the personalty dimensions exist on a continuum. Meaning just like
with intelligence, if you plot the entire population, you'll only get a few
people at the extreme highs or the extreme lows of each dimension. But most
people would end up here, in the middle. If we plotted the frequency of the
entire population, we would get a bell shape curve or normal distribution. So
most of us, about 68% of us, would score around the mean. But then we'll see
that around 2% of people are either really high or really low in any given
dimension. What this also shows us is that there's a high and the low in to all
the personalities dimensions. For example, let's look at extroversion. On the
high end we have, well extroversion, and on the low end we have introversion.
And now, look at agreeableness. On the high end we have, well, agreeableness
and on the low end we have hostility or coldness. So, as you can see, the big
five uses the high end as the labels, but there are still two sides to things,
the highs and the lows.